so we're here to talk about your new
show arrow but I can't start off with
our I've gotta start off of course with
team world because you got so many team
or funds out there of Carlton obviously
they miss you on the show what was it
like leaving it was it was really
heartbreaking I mean people think that
you know at most the time when people
leave shows it's be for a bad reason
this was not for a bad reason at all and
you know I I just I had to take it well
I wanted to be in all the episodes and
it didn't work out that way so I had to
take her you know take a take a leap for
myself and arrow came along and then now
I'm happier to be on that show you know
I still I the other day we had screening
a team will fit on our creator Jeff
Davis's house and I still for him out
with all them every day they're always
going to my family so that's all that
matters to me so was it like filming his
love scenes
well the here's the issue was is at the
time I didn't know that I was gonna go
back to the show so you know I they had
or two alternate endings where I either
died or I became a werewolf and they
picked the one why became a werewolf
where I lived and then I ended up not
returning which was really sad but
they'd been in the story line this year
they said Jackson is now the American
Werewolf in London so I'm in London
right now oh I'm hearing yeah weird I
need what you know knows maybe you know
maybe there's a camera here trying to
film Jackson in London no yeah Jackson
in reality yeah Jackson is actually in
London right yeah you got yet to you
know get to still I'd love for all my
team of fans who have actually still
stayed with me you know through the
arrow through the arrow face so you know
they're still great
they still tweet me all the time so yeah
good stuff and what's it been like I'm
shooting arrow your pardon the pun
compared to teen well you know it's it's
completely different it's it's you know
team offers a lot about the
relationships like really close
relationships and also they've a lot of
special effects makeup with arrow it's a
lot of you know they do there are really
great relationships but there's it's on
a really massive scale you know we have
cranes flying and hitting the point we
have so many cameras filming and they've
just got such a great budget and the
shows just had such a success and they
do to the comic book fans and you know
do 2dc that they were able to do so many
things with with arrow and you know
we're able to shoot so many things that
some of it doesn't even make doesn't
even make it on a TV so you never know
what what you're gonna be talking about
you know when you're doing press cuz you
some of the fans didn't actually get to
see a lot of things you've done and and
which is exciting because you know keeps
you on your toes
so definitely what were the things in
the last season that you thought that
didn't make it it would be great if it
had or wonder if it'll be on the DVD
well there was a lot of besides a lot of
the bloopers that come from me trying to
instead of you know do choreography
doing that the fight choreography it
looks like I'm actually in a boy band or
doing hip hop dancing which is not where
you're supposed to be doing when you're
trying to do a fight cinema so it's like
me not quite understanding choreography
but Heather's that and there's also um
there's a really really great scene
between a few great scenes between Thea
and I kind of explaining a little more
about a relationship and possibly
explaining things that we were going to
do together to help help save a few
people but I think they wanted to keep
it more mystery so they can drag it out
to the second season so that's what
that's gonna be exciting for the fans
because they're gonna get to see
something that's been in the works for
you know at by the time the show comes
out at mid October is when the second
season comes out you know something has
been in the works for six months
so it's gonna be really exciting and
it's gonna be great to see their
reaction to those scenes yeah so will
you kind of be reliving moments that
were left out in that first season with
Thea or taking things a different
direction or do you know yet how it'll
work I do know that that within within
the very first episode you we find out
that there is a time jump of form of
time jump so at that point ruin Thea's
relationship is you know really real
they're really in it and you know
obviously they're young so anything can
happen with young love but you know I've
watched TV shows where people stay
together for years on years and you know
gone through the hardships together for
five seasons but um I feel like
they're gonna be faced with a really
really hard decision based upon who
finds out who unmasks the hood and who
who does it first so you never know if
one masks the hood first Roy now knows
that Thea's brother is the vigilante you
know so advising it you know would he
keep that from her you know you never
know if she's gonna find out it's you
know it's gonna it could turn into a
triangle of really deadly my triangle
darkness in a way you know yeah gosh
don't know secret oh there's gonna be a
lot of secrets and I have a feeling that
you know Emily Emily records character
and Felicity Smoak is going to UM I have
a feeling she because she obviously
knows everything that's going on with
within the group so um you know if
people are going to her for information
she you know she could be a big asset to
uh helping keep the identity secret for
Oliver
it's a whole thing and really
interesting dynamic don't you think yeah
it's it's there's so many different
things that they can do and it's great
because the first season is obviously
about introducing a lot of characters
and and things like that which they've
done with a great job at but now we
disguise the limit with what where they
can go with everything and who you think
is you know actually a good guy in a
sense could actually just be you know
just trying to help the bad guys out so
ooh
excitement hey a mountain I'm trying not
to give everything I've got there's
gonna be always no because I was know if
the interviews that I don't give too
much away the the executive roosters
like regular Lance here Marc Guggenheim
or Andrew Kreisberg they will they'll
retweet it or they'll tweet about it so
I'm like okay I still have a job if I
god let's move a little bit away from
spoilers and let's move on to I know 15
will frequent we had a very intense
fitness regime going didn't you and you
have been tweeting some kind of gym
shots like we haven't used well you're
still keeping that for all right but how
does it compare for that you training in
a different way at all I'm I'm
definitely a different way for Teen Wolf
I put on 20 pounds which which for me is
I mean I've been a runner my entire life
and play tennis and things like that and
I'm naturally my whole family's actually
kind of small so um I hadn't
muscles really difficult because you
have to I mean most people are like you
have to eat all day that's amazing but
no like you actually have to eat all day
and you get tired and you feel sick all
the time so now I'm gonna take I'm
taking a departure from that and I'm I
think I'm just putting on 10 pounds and
doing it with not really using these
supplements just doing a healthy and
just trying to stay away from me you
know cardio but just having to do heavy
weights and things like that so I mean
with training means probably have to be
shirtless again and you know which is
nerve-wracking but you get over it
eventually so you know I have to keep up
with the Greek guy don't even call him
Stephen Amell I just call him Greek god
his first name in Greek and it's he's
not in Greek but he just looks like a
statue yeah is it nervously those scenes
where you have to do that you know it's
not it's funny because it's like it's
all smoke and mirrors with with TV you
know so like everyone that has like
romantic love scenes and things like
that it's you're not just going at it
there are play you know you have to be
placed the right way there's things you
like that so every when their scenes
like that obviously you want to look
your best and you want to you want you
know the product to come out they've
actually been working hard at working
out or you just you know make do a good
angle and make it look like you've been
working out and yeah you beg them to
photoshop in some extra abs and then you
might feel like slipped them a few 20s
but I would never do that I would use a
body bubble or anything for four ab
shots that never happens in film or TV
I've actually never done that but now
that I'm saying it can I'd love to do
that so if I could take a few days off
from the gym I would love if they could
just let me do that I use the body
double for me for the makeup on Teen
Wolf because I was allergic to the
makeup so I think just find some like
really rip dude to like just do all my
sure listens then I'd have the best job
in the world
yeah maybe something to scream puts than
when you're back well I need a clip out
of my death well the issue is I just
signed my contract so now I can't add
things in there I should have put must
have Shirley's body double on set who is
a supermodel yeah yes season three
hopefully they have the fans keep
watching so they can help me out with
that
yes
you